mike miner who had a tough time on the
road he pitched 10 innings combined
against
the rangers and the red sox and gave up
14 earned runs
yeah mike miner is going to put that
pass behind him right now alejo
lopez will lead off chopped out to short
lopez to lopez one away money
every time that balls hit the shortstop
i look down to my card and right in
before i even see the play that's how
automatically nikki lopez has been
mike miner's 2-2 pitch with nobody on
two out and a foul tip and a strikeout
and that's the inning so a great start
for minor ground ball a fly ball and a
strikeout and after half an inning
cincinnati nothing royals coming up
gutierrez if you could take out the
numbers against the san diego padres now
we know you can't do that but if you
could
his numbers would look terrific i mean
the padres just beat him up and
sometimes
one team has your number but i think
for gutierrez in this ball game those
first three batters in the order that
you were talking about i think that's
where you've got to really
you've got to show your talent if you're
gutierrez those are the three guys that
you've got to keep
off the base pass or at least limit the
damage
in that top of the order with merrifield
and here's the 2-2
and there's a fastball well thrown right
on the outside corner strike three
called mere fields down on strikes and
there's one away it's a tough strikeout
right there for mirrorfield he is by far
their best overall professional hitter
as far as being able to
hit in situations hit the ball the other
way took a perfect fastball at 95
to get him right-hander turns it loose
first pitch to o'hern
sharp ground ball right side easy play
in the shift
gutierrez works around a walk-in we have
zeroes on the board
some minor struggles with men in scoring
position
suarez to the backhand of lopez feeds
merrifield one on a first
in time double play the stevenson breaks
from third he scores
red's on the board it's one to nothing
this breaking ball was supposed to be
inside it ends up
back door and suarez right over the top
of it
tyler naquin pulls it on the ground to
the right side with dives he's got it
and as he throws he stumbled and he's
called out by first base umpire
scott berry there will be no challenge
so an excellent play by whitmerfield
to get a speedy tyler naquin who was
roaring down that first base line that
is a terrific play
when out nobody on the battle will be
mike freeman 2-2
is hit back to the mount easy play for
mike in the top of the mound he throws
out freeman two down
now we head back to the top of the order
and alejo lopez
miner gets the sign from salvador perez
and brings the 2-2
and it's swung on hit in the air shallow
center field taylor comes running over
towards left center
and makes a nice running catch so three
up three down
it's the reds one the royals nothing
bottom of the third inning cincinnati
leads it
one nothing and the reds will bring the
infield in for carlos santana
carlos has driven in 47. elevated
fastball is cranked into right center
field
that'll get the run home and it also
will get santana to second base
he was getting closer and closer exactly
right you could tell by the way he's
fouling balls up high fastball
put it right in his wheelhouse he tagged
it and he stayed on top and had some
downward breaking so it's able to sit
down here and
outfielder could not catch it nice job
give wood half of that rbi for getting
into second base
i mean you hit him over to third exit
velo 105.
he squared it up nicely if the ball
starts in the middle of the plate to
this guy
as soon as he sees it then it's close
he's swinging
right back to it swing at a miss strike
three it's back-to-back case for
gutierrez he has now
struck out five royals and you've got a
hitter that reads the ball
way out before it gets anywhere close to
the plate you start it in the middle
get it off the plate and you'll get
those ugly swings all day
hanser alberto swing and a miss struck
him out and down on strikes hanzer
alberto 2-2
sharply stun nice pick by vatto
he has said he's been working on his
defense and he's made
several plays in the last couple of
weeks gutierrez is rolling
maybe solaire can pick them all up he's
due
it's one and one there's a line drive
and that's going to go
all the way to the wall santana will
score perez racing to third the ball is
bobbled
and they're going to hold salvi at third
base and the royals lead 2-1 in the
sixth inning
oh that was a good sound off of his bat
he'll take the slider that was hanging
in the middle
reds one run on two hits all of that
action came in the second
it's part of the order starting with
nick castiano's
first pitch he clocks it to left center
field
and nick castellanos ties the game
can this guy come up any larger
in any bigger situations than what we
have seen over the last two weeks
my goodness the legend of castellanos
continues to grow
the silence is beautiful pitching change
for the royals as they
dipped into their bullpen for the first
time tonight mike miner
line still open leaves in a tie game
kyle zimmer
who has been great avoiding bats one of
the lowest hits per nine rates in
baseball is in
two on a run in nobody out
and suarez unloads a mammoth shot to
left field
sacalam to the back of the picnic
section that's the old day eugenio right
there and that was a breaking ball and
he absolutely destroyed it
good for him what feels like the most
monstrous homer
of suarez's campaign and he thunders the
reds on top
five to two well that was an absolute
no doubter oh my goodness that thing was
way back there
now the infield has to come in nobody
out tyler and ink went a chance for an
rbi
first pitch that is throw basic aquino
scores they quinn turn slams on the
brakes
rushes back he'll take his rbi single
reds lengthen their lead it's six
to two stayed on the plate just a bit
too long
and as you mentioned earlier john maquin
has really
been going the other way with some
authority and that was
authoritative so now second and third
two down
reds trying to make it five straight
wins 2-0
bounce left side in suarez low-bound
one-footed throw
in time and the rally reds strike again
they come from behind and they win
a fifth consecutive game it's their
first run of
five straight comeback wins since may of
1995.
they rally past the royals six to two
that's my team that's how you do it
greatness accompanies greatness